[Music]
[Applause]
good morning
today as my talk it is the morning of my
talk we just got ready we're about to
head to the venue I just I ran through
my talk once earlier and I feel pretty
good about it
even though I completely missed an
entire part my talk isn't until like
5:30 it's not for a while so I'm talking
to me there's a little table
[Music]
it's got a nervous about me giving a
talk why it was question yes sorry what
was the question
yeah thank you there's one hour until my
talk I'm
[Music]
I'm just reading through my slides
there's one hour until my talk and I
think I'm going to explode and die
either now or on stage
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
what's going on this I mean there's
workshops tomorrow you're done
[Music]
[Applause]